[Music]
don't be a fake
don't be a flake don't run away from
your feelings babe don't be afraid
don't be ashamed don't hesitate to say
hey babe
hey babe hey babe hey
[Music]
what's up babe how are you doing how are
you doing you got some problems
ah yeah this grunt that that grossed you
out a little bit
but no boogers on it no boogers on it a
little better
relatively dry that actually that bag's
getting some weight to it got a tissue i
gave you this bag
15 minutes ago and i looked like you
went shopping for like a half hour
looking
through a lot of tissues wow so
i took a cover test i'm kovy wove free
but the
owls you can call chris al
what's that you can call me al i shorten
allergies to al
and then i put your name in a song by
by uh simon uh paul simon yeah it really
it took a [ __ ] you know what something
you could you know what it's another one
you could get funky with is you could
say my al jazeera's are on fire
i like that yeah americans use upwards
of
255 trillion 300 and no 255 billion
360 million
disposable facial tissues a year yep
billions wow just in america what a
trillion
tissues i would say kleenex i've used
i've used in the span of the last
fifteen to twenty minutes
fifty-five of your shoes firing through
them firing through
i cannot stop sneezing and it's clear
liquid snot juice
which is telling me it's allergies
tissues can be manufactured using trees
that are turned into wood chips
and then cooked to separate the fiber
from the glue that holds the tree
together
this fiber is then formed into a sheet
and ultimately into a tissue
you're you're destroying the rainfall
i'm destroying the rainforest i've had
enough for the trees hey what's up
everybody i'm back on the road doing
stand up go to chrisdcomedy.com
check the website see if your city's on
there we got a lot of shows sold out
we're adding a lot of shows i appreciate
the fan support so much that's
chrisdcomedy.com what do you do you go
kleenex you go puffs
you go target brand what do you do what
do you like no i go
i go puffs is there a tissue brand
besides kleenex and puffs that are like
that are front runners
i i couldn't name one besides snacks
puffs or no frills
or no oh yeah or or the rite aid brand
or whatever it is yeah but besides
but the name brands kleenex and puffs i
think it's kleenex and puffs
and yeah i think it's kleenex and puffs
and you wonder why charmin hasn't
released the tissue paper for the nose
holy tissue paper for the butt they
focus heavy on the ass shaman on the ass
shaman it probably came up in meetings
and the ceo or the president was like if
another person brings up a nose
yeah i told you where it's going to be a
very ass summer
yeah we're focusing on butt holes yeah
because you would think
the same comfort and softness that i
applied to my butthole with charmin
i would also like to apply to my nose
shout out charming you shout out sharman
shout out tissue products
shout out cold shout out solutions to
colds one day maybe you wanna throw
sharma wants to throw us a promo code
we're listening you ever see the shaman
commercials they get cutesy because they
put a cartoon bear in there like we
don't know he's gotta wipe his ass
yeah you know what i mean they get a
little cute with it they don't just show
some huge dude on the ball being like
flush and be like ah did you see the
video of the teenager
who bought who literally hip checked a
bear because the bear was coming over
the fence to eat her dogs
no first of all the video says it's a
teenager but this woman looks like she's
an eight-year-old italian woman
but it says it's a yeah look at this
california teenager fights off bear
attacking dogs
watch this look at this look at this
watch this this was this is it's a
straight up you saw this pimp this is
crazy you saw it yeah look at this
watch this holy [ __ ] it's a bear oh my
god it's a full grizzly yeah with the
kids
no yes it's got the the bear and the two
kids mama bear
wow she's she must have escaped from the
dogs come out and start talking [ __ ]
and the bear's swiping at the dogs yo
the dog's not backing down
that big is sw oh my god
threw the bear right off the thing but
where's the mini dog
no everybody got away but that's a
teenager she looks like a fifty
seven-year-old woman wow she did what
you would do in prison she walked right
up to the biggest
the biggest bear and she punched him
right in the throat yeah
now what would you do would you just say
prison well in that well yes we're gonna
get to that
yes but also if bears are attacking your
dogs
she was in a good position i'll tell you
why okay that bear was on the top of
that ledge that cement ledge
and she had she had a balance on her
side
because all she did was shove that
barrel off like he was a punk ass
balance in her side
also she had jesus on her side she had
both yeah if that bear was on the floor
with her
and like on the ground where she wasn't
she went to shove it every one of those
people
the video would have been about 10
minutes longer we would have watched the
bear eat every one of them
every single one of them i said that
bear must have escaped from the circus
because
like that high wire act that he was
coming in on just the kids
we saw a live video of a bear training
his cubs to be in the circus yes then
this woman came in and messed it up
i'll tell you what i just came from the
la brea tar pits and the la
just before you yeah it came with the
range armpits
they had they had a a a statue of a bear
that a prehistoric bear that they found
standing on its hind legs i think it was
called the short hair black bear
this thing stood about 19 feet on its
high legs
it was humongous shout out library tarps
it actually smells like a fart
in there because the tar pit is still
seeping the same tar
that woolly mammoths and saber two
tigers got caught in
it's the same tar that's right there in
la brea right now the great targets
short hair black bear don't care yeah
yeah they brought me
out look at that thing this labrador
tarpon's bear was the biggest
most intimidating thing okay there's a
lot of pam can you go back to that
because there's a lot of preconceived
notions about what you do
what do you know from just from from
people's comments
like from pop culture that you're
supposed to do if you get attacked by a
bear have you i've heard multiple things
okay okay
i don't if i get attacked by a bear is
it stop drop and roll
i think that is a fire okay
is it is it a revenant with leonardo
dicaprio all too real did you see the
bear attack
yes wild right wild like it was hard to
watch
well let me take another stab assistant
okay so it's not stop drop and roll
is it i'm just telling you what i know
okay is it you s
uh sit still and don't move a muscle
because it can't really see
things that aren't moving you can only
see thing it can't see it yeah it can't
really
that's a t-rex that's from jurassic park
yeah that's a t-rex
yeah well is it that what it was yeah i
think yeah
i heard about two games i heard two
things and they're both opposite things
one i heard is don't play dead okay
play dead and then how do you play dead
by the way if do you know i
i was in front of two grizzly bezos of
fighting and i was like right in front
of them
on the show they put me in a cage with
grizzlies what and and they
they put me in a cage the size of my
body and then they they let me out to a
grizzly bear farm
and then they threw they threw fried
chicken because bears love fried chicken
they threw fried chicken at the cage and
got it stuck in the cage and then bears
came and ate the fried chicken from the
cage and got into a fight in front of my
face
that's me
let me ask you this we're just looking
at this at this video or still image of
of the grizzly bear thing right now
what's the point of the helmet
they're gonna rip that they'll rip your
head clean off i think the helmet was
like
we're a gopro okay but it was so not now
no dude the bear the bear you if you've
never been that close to a bear
when they just slightly growl it sounds
like like you're at the indy 500 and the
cars are passing
really like the reverberation from their
chest and
oh their breath smells like a smell i've
never smelled in my entire life
disgusting
it smells like a combination of like
like bare intestine whatever that might
be
plus all sorts of oddities like fish and
whatevers you ever seen the video of the
bear attacking the deer
you ever seen this i don't know what you
want you want to really be uncomfortable
i this is nature though look it's just
nature look
listen listen i can't watch it i can't
watch it you can watch it it's just the
sound listen to the sound of the yellow
you
ah it'll haunt me it'll haunt me it'll
haunt my dreams but this is nature i
know but you know what sometimes
nature's not for me
okay and i have a question when you're
doing the joker's bit how many hours you
in that cage i actually almost passed
out in that cage because
what they had the original yeah the heat
my god the heat
it was like 100 degrees right and i was
already nervous and they put me in this
thing
and they had to strap me in they were so
nervous that i would put my
accidentally put my hands near the cage
and that would get swiped off that they
tied my hand they want to tie my hands
and
tie my chest down and tie my feet in so
that even if a bear tried to get in it
wouldn't get close enough to me
so i have a little close to
claustrophobic
and so in the heat in there tied down
on camera they they will because okay
what happened was
i wasn't just in that cage that cage was
gift wrapped
[Laughter]
so they gave give the bears a present so
the bears came and ripped
ripped the present open but when they
closed up the present in the gift wrap
it was really like pieces of wood
yeah see and so there was no air getting
in there and it was 95 degrees
and oh my god i don't know if it's on
camera but like
if it made it to air but i almost passed
out like
live on camera i was going like this and
i was going guys i'm going to pass out
i'm going to pass
and i kept like losing and were they
just laughing at you no they were they
like running over and like spraying me
and like opening a piece of the gift and
letting aaron oh my god yeah yeah
there's there's a po there's a point in
this
bit where the two bears fight right in
front of me and one takes a swipe and
one tries to bite the other one
and i literally i think i pushed [ __ ]
and vomited at the same exact time did
you really actually truthfully do duty
in your pants did you do
no but might as well might as well yeah
if there was anything there to come out
it would have came out so how long were
you actually in the cage though
uh an hour maybe what oh my god
yeah was that one of those now is that
when you film something like that is
that is that the only thing you do that
day or did they they say all right now
we're going to do
you just you just um it's it's the only
usually it's the only thing i'll do that
day
sometimes we double up look at that yeah
like out of nowhere dude i don't know
you just feel like they want to get in
that cage they could not
yeah and was that scream terrifying
i mean i probably scream if you put up
the volume i probably scream and
they'll rip the sound is so deep that it
rattles your
chest now let me ask you a question
let's say
let's say the bear girl say
boy say let's say
let's say
what would it happen what would happen
if they did
rip off the front of the cage what's the
protocol then is there somebody there
with a tranquilizer gun
yeah there was somebody there with a
trunk i mean i don't know if they had a
trunk gun but there was the
there was the trainers that they are
like that that own the
whatever the reservation we were on or
whatever but i don't know what they're
gonna do
they're gonna be like you know like what
are they gonna say
like spike don't like what else is that
the bear's name
his name is imagine its name was like
melissa
his name was edna melissa please come on
um
did you ever see have you ever seen a
moose live in person
yeah they're prehistoric brick [ __ ]
houses look google moose
walking in street and they have it where
it's going to kill you
it's three times the size of it i'm
talking about it in finnick
look at this look at how big this moose
is this is for real jesus
it looks like it looks fake it looks
like it looks pink
it's twice it's three times the size of
it
it looks fake look at how big the boost
is
and they're fast it looks like a
dinosaur yeah
yeah look at that it looks like a
legitimate dinosaur it's the biggest
moose they've ever seen
ah them too like you you gotta steer
clear of them
don't go anywhere near them they'll
charge you like an elephant oh so with
the bears right
play dead which by the way if a bear
comes over and starts nipping at you a
little bit
you know it's just to see like let me
see if this is lunch or not or whatever
it is and then you
how are you supposed to play dead do
that yeah like i mean i guess
you can't get up at that point no so you
so you you just
i mean people have been in this
situation that's what i'm saying like
we're like playing little games here i
mean like imagine imagine
but like people have been in a situation
where they're just like there's a
there's a two thousand pound bear above
them and they're just like just don't do
anything but then i also heard stand up
and put your arms up and be like so
you're
so you're like challenging because if
you get tall like that's like showing
them that like you're
you know you're flexing what i do no yes
did you hear that
i i did no i did but what i actually do
this is why because you asked me once
why do you always do this
i constantly wherever i go i always make
sure that i have three to four
packs of salmon in case i get attacked
by a bear i throw the salmon
and then i run away thousands of days
not using that salmon
it doesn't thousands of potatoes the day
that comes that the bear is there
well because of the overpopulation
problem we have we're slow more and more
we're we're you know increasing
encroaching upon
wild bears wild me smooshes habitats
miso soup miso soups
horny um so that's what
shout out for the old virgin you so
crazy yes
what's 40 year old virgin the movie with
steve carrell no but why did you shout
it out because he goes me so horny
shout out to live crew yeah shout out to
left crew you know what's cool about the
bears i found out that
the bears all the bears that uh attack
humans in national parks
they cage them and ship them to
yellowstone and yellowstone has all the
most aggressive bears yellowstone's like
rikers
that's hilarious yellow stone it's like
australia
it's back in the day when they shipped
criminals to australia yellow sodas the
rikers have been
oh that's so funny like these bands are
like tear drops on
[Laughter]
gag affiliated there yeah okay he's
flashing claws so let's
slash he's like so let's say let's
let's see what it says so it says fight
back if a bear actually attacks
fight back use anything and everything
is a weapon
rock sticks fists and your teeth aim
your blows
on the bear's face particularly the eyes
and snout
when a black bear sees that their victim
is willing to fight to the death they
usually just give up well
you think you got what it takes that's a
black bear though i think black bears
are a little bit more
like user friendly black bears docile i
think they come for the garbage but you
can be like shoo shoo
so the brown bear
so here with the bear let's go what is
the most dangerous top five most
dangerous babies i think the thing you
don't want to do is turn your back and
run
right right i got attacked by a cloud
leopard by turning my back
a cloud i was invited to the nashville
zoo for like behind the scenes taste
okay like we're going in at all the
cages and everything every time i go to
nashville i have a connect there
and we take the backyard the back way
big on nashville
big i love nash who doesn't live in nash
bridges you ever watch that me neither
no
uh stephen asheville and they they got
these baby cloud leopards right i
actually have pictures of me holding
they were this big we were feeding them
there was one this little this little
year or two later i go back they go do
you want to see the cloud leopard that
you held in your arms when it was just
birthed yeah they take me to this
huge cage and there's trees in the cage
and everything and the snow leopard is
now about
it'll kill you kill you in a heartbeat
but
you don't think it's like a really it's
like the size of a dog almost like a
medium-sized dog maybe even bigger but
no it's a killing machine though
okay so they're like you'll be all right
you'll be all right just don't turn your
back on it right
and i didn't like you know i don't know
why i turned my back on it but i didn't
really but like it was on the thing
and i turned a little bit and it went
like this and it
swiped and left a bloody claw mark on my
arm like from the like
something you'd see like out of it
swiped and literally clawed out and i
was like whoa
whoa oh and i was like damn i didn't do
anything i just kind of turned to the
i just slightly turned and it swiped at
me why do you believe that [ __ ] because
what is it it just thinks you're i think
it's like
it's a prey thing where it's like if you
turn it feels like it can
get you or something i don't know like
what's the respect thing so you turn
your back on me yeah
that's what yeah that's kind of probably
like really you know on the slow level
yeah don't you dare turn your back don't
you dare turn your back on me yeah
now i wanted to wha oh there was good
but a bear you're gonna square up with
us a bear or you're gonna just be like
it's one of the other you either have to
be like you know well i have well i do i
do do
cardio kickboxing two to three times a
week yeah so with that being said
google uh grizzly bear attack slash
cardio kickbox question mark yes see
where it comes let's see what happens
let's see what happens yeah because i'm
thinking
i love that you actually google that
like something's gonna look like a
result's gonna come up
now if you were going to get eaten by an
animal yeah what animal would you prefer
to be eaten by
oh something that's going to do it quick
can i say dino because that's just a
bite i'm a ch i'm like
i'm like a flintstone vitamin to them
right yeah
i don't know i kind of think i kind of
think i don't want to get eaten by any
animal
but i kind of think if i was going to
get invited animal i'd rather be eaten
by an animal that's also going to
simultaneously drown me
because i think the pain and fear of
drowning will
outweigh the pain of having my flesh
being eaten but you're getting both what
do you mean like like a guy
when you're drowning like a hippo yeah
hippo got to be a bad way i'd probably
rather go
has there ever been a human being eaten
by a hippopotamus it has to be by the
cartoon
by the cartel he had all those hippos
that's why they have a hippo problem
where the cartel used to be based he
would feed uh pablo escobar would feed
him to the hippos
get that hell out of here hungry hungry
hippos whoa
you rather get attacked by a hippo or a
gator
i think a gator locks so maybe it's less
painful than like just continual chomps
yeah but a hippo's got to be
you know from what i know from cartoons
and stuff
don't hippos just have like dull molars
they look they don't look like they're
very little
they just have like human teeth in hippo
forms gotta be a powerful bite
that's gotta that's gotta break your leg
off cleaning a chomp right lean in a
chunk
i don't necessarily know if an alligator
is breaking your leg off
in one felt swoop of a like a chomp but
a hippo is swallow chewed and drowned by
hippos
hippos are remarkably agile and
aggressive
they occasionally kill or scavenge
impala kudu and buffalo
sometimes they even kill humans on
nightly sojourns
out of the water hippos trek miles to
nibble on tasty vegetation including
crops
making humans and hippos unnecessary
uneasy neighbors wow
they eat chevy impalas wow that's
an easy that i mean that's very hard to
do i could see if they could eat they
could eat right through a tesla what is
that chevy impala what is a hippo's life
what is it you just float around half
out of the water and then
yeah you walk a few miles to nibble on
something out of the water and then you
walk
yeah you eat a few vegetables hippo is
amongst the most dangerous animal in the
world
highly aggressive and unpredictable
nature that's why nobody has a pet
hippopotamus
how do they let me ask you this how are
they so fast how are they so bottom
heavy
before they do it is walking miles and
miles miles to nibble on vegetation
hippos got that ass though where they
get that as far as that ass but where
hippos get that ass from if they're
gonna just walk
walk it out they eat fatty veg fatty
vegetables
four hippopotamuses were kept by pablo
escobar in the late 70s and upon his
death they were allowed to wander
his unattended estate by 2019 their
population had grown to approximately
100.
his four just ancestrally banged and
created
oh what about an incestual hippo that
thing with a wonky eye just chomping and
chopping it up
causing the times that they might harm
the native flora and
fauna in the area don't know what those
things are it'd be very hard for me by
the way to play
dead to try to save my life from a bear
during allergy season
very difficult for me yeah because you
depending on the season i can't look at
this
you'll be running from him holding the
bag yeah how many i think we're 38
tissues in by the way yeah but let me
ask you a question
before i get to this though how how much
how quickly are you discarding a tissue
you know what i think i think i'm in the
camp of people that uses the tissue
a little too long right i always like
because i think i'm going to run it
through and if i run through and i need
more i'm gonna be screwed
so i try to get like a couple of uses
out of one tissue not if i have like a
cold and i'm just blowing [ __ ] out of my
body right but if it's
like a general nose blow like you said
like i might fold it twice and like put
it in the pock is that gross
it's not gross but i would for me i use
tissues like toilet paper one wipe and
it's gone
oh you don't you don't use like toilet
paper like 10 times
no once i wipe once yeah it's gone gone
gone it's right you apply one ply what
are you doing here i go probably two
yeah i go two-ply um
but i've been i've been being told i was
told this
for years i mean by my mother i can as
long as i can remember that i use too
much toilet paper
i'm the guy use a roll of toilet paper i
don't think there's a parent out there
though
to to assuage your concerns that uh
that that say their kids don't use too
much toilet paper right i think that's
square one for parents right you know i
never heard someone be like you know
about something about my daughter
very efficient with the toilet paper no
nobody ever yeah my my daughter likes to
wipe her butt
uh you know the proper amount wipe a
bite and then take the roll of toilet
paper and throw it in the toilet bowl
she likes to do that
so i'll quite
she just throws the roll in there just
for no reason she's like i don't even
wipe my ass i just take the whole
throw in the toilet and just give
everyone the finger what she was doing
for about six months we had no idea why
is
when the toilet paper roll would finish
and she'd be the one using it she would
just do her business whatever take the
toilet
take the toilet paper roll and put them
in like a little box she had in the back
of her room so one day we were cleaning
her room
we found i'm not talking i'm not lying
about 25 just
discarded like the brown cardboard
toilet paper
oh yeah you know you know what you know
what's trick i learned about that i saw
someone doing once
they were smoking weed inside their home
yeah of course pimp knows this
yeah and they put like a dryer sheet or
like uh what do you call that like um
when
the fabrics off in the shade they stuff
a bunch of those
inside a paper towel or toilet paper
roll right and then they put like a
paper towel and they rub abandoned on
the end
and then they blow jesus christ i really
hope it's allergies
um and then they not okay and then they
blow it into the toilet paper roll
so that this the it it's a filter
so so you the smoke the weed smoke goes
it gets caught into the dryer sheets
okay and it doesn't and it doesn't come
out the other you know about this
they did that in college a lot they
called them sploofs i think never heard
that but yeah let me ask you a question
you know every time
let me just sound like what that should
be called sploof
sounds like what do you think sploof
sounds like sploof
if you said what if you said given the
definition of a sploof yeah i would
think that a sploof
is when i would say that's when a
painter takes like that that what that
like ball like thing and
and paints the wall with like oh that's
such a good guess
wait but are you saying that my
daughter's sploofing and i need to have
a sit down with me here
i'm saying that she's sick she's getting
smart and wise to the world now maybe
she watches the patreon or something
she gets ideas so we need to keep the
dryer sheets away from my daughter would
be hysterical if she was just
wailing away a weed in the room and you
just found a bucket of sploofs
well yo her american girl dolls are all
smoking
doesn't have tea parties she just has
she just smokes all the american girl
dolls out
my daughter's doing yeah my daughter's
doing ayahuasca tea parties with the
american girl
do you have any dryer sheets yeah
hippo's skin is bulletproof that now we
let's shoot a hippo on the patreon
we've gotta test it we wanna shoot
hippos right now
it can however be removed with a zipper
located underneath the
torso of the animal with the zipper if
you plan on shooting a hippo your best
bet is seducing it first
wait what wait where hold on wait wait
so now they're saying if you want to
shoot and kill a hippo you got to also
have sex with it
i don't have sex with it what what the
hell was that about what the hell
article was that if
they said there's that sounds like an
article that homeless pimp wrote after
imagine not knowing that a hippo's skin
is bulletproof
finding yourself in a place where a
hippo might attack you
having a gun and thinking it's not the
last day for me
pulling it out being like block of block
of blocka hitting the hippo with three
in the dome
and the hippo's like nah my skin's just
but then you just get chomped by those
dull
human moles yeah like it's like like in
the movie the mask it just [ __ ] takes
the bullets and it just starts shooting
it back at you
i wonder if dinosaur skin was
bulletproof then as well i would imagine
yeah it's got to be a hard outer shell
so almost like a
jurassic park's [ __ ] then you can't
cheat those dinosaurs what what's what's
that what's that magic shell that you
put on like ice cream in a hardens
magic shell yeah a magical shell like
from the like the ice cream truck
yeah yeah like and it hardens yes like
like you put chocolate and then it gets
stiff
yeah it's a treat that's that's true you
just gave me some edible arrangement
treats i appreciated that did you like
that chocolate covered bananas and uh
and uh
chocolate covered cheesecake was good
yeah it was just an edible arrangement
shout out to the bull rangers about
anything edible that's arranged
you notice i said before about kleenex
shout out what about what about
here let me just just real quick how
about this is a business please
edible arranged marriages what do you
think of that so you so
you you so you're giving a bride or a
husband and then and then you're dipped
in chocolate
they're different when they arrive and
you eat them you don't have to eat them
but they're dipped in chocolate
what would you do if you were arranged
would you get arranged you think you
could make an arranged marriage work
people do it seems if that's the culture
you know i guess that's it you just be
like all right
but it's it got us it has to suck though
if you get arranged with someone and
you they are ugly they have or they have
a thing they have to be
stomach passable yeah they can't have
like and they can't have stuff like
halitosis or something oh you can't do
it well like yeah or like
yeah like just weird feet or something
like that yeah i could get over weird
feet
you can get over weird feet i mean if i
had to i'd rather i'd rather have
someone have weird feet than bad breath
their whole life
if i was gonna get arranged right could
you date a
person with missing a limb uh
sure why not yeah with no prosthetic
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah no sure i
could do that
yeah of course what about someone who
has a limb but their arm their arm is
very small like a birth defect but they
have like
like a nub of an arm with you know what
about that sure
sure yeah why wouldn't i no i don't know
could you yeah what about person with
one eye could you do that
no problem yeah i mean i i you know
there's probably everything but that i i
probably could like about them still
what about a full-blown
terrorist
[Laughter]
that's where i might draw the line right
but if you had a connection
maybe i know they're a terrorist they're
fully they're open
but other than when they're doing the
terrorism stuff they're just top-notch
they have all four limbs in both eyes
but the catch is they're
they're a terrorist oh no it had to be
on
what if you what if you didn't know they
were terrorists you fell in love and you
found out they were a terrorist
what about that i mean deep though deep
you find out
three is in you guys have matching
shirts and [ __ ] you know you're into a
real couple [ __ ] you're a beautiful
couple
i would say would you try to get them
away from terrorism or would you be like
i am scorned i can't believe you didn't
tell me this this is
an atrocity you're a terrible person i
mean you might think you have your
reasons but terrorism of any kind is
just not for me
and then would you just or would you
just be like what if the sex was great
like what if like everything
you bang it on all cylinders with this
person and then what if it was like
a minor one like like okay a bomb
no no injuries no injuries and then and
then they got out of it
they got out of it but they said that
bomb was me there was no one injured
and i'm not gonna do it anymore i could
deal with that i could deal with that
and
and i don't see even if they were full
scale like i'm talking about a
full-scale
full-scale no-holds bar active
international terrorists but i was in
love with them
i was passed out i would say
no what are you
it's not because you're in love with
them i know that's superseded i know but
you know you heard the song sometimes
love just ain't enough
baby sometimes love just ain't enough
i couldn't do it by the way pimp just
pulled something up that was wild
it said that let's go back to the video
50 there's a 40 to 50
divorce rate in the united states
there's a 90 percent
uh um there's a 90 arranged marriage
rate in india and only a one percent
divorce rate
wow so it is literally almost unheard of
you're locked in yeah that's wild so
you know what's one thing i notice about
is you always have a nice hard [ __ ]
[Laughter]
your secret you're very perceptive
because i try to keep that
out of people's sight lines i've noticed
it so
what is it about your rocking hot boner
i didn't always have that it all started
when we started getting sponsored by
blue chew
that's what i did okay so that's what it
is because all of a sudden now it's like
you get up you turn the light switch on
and off yeah yeah cause you just got a
boner the whole show
that's right and i like to just have
boners in regular life yeah not for even
when i'm being intimate a lot of people
take that blue true
when they want to be intimate me i like
taking the blue chew and just
feeling my way through the day yeah the
other day and good morning america i
said somebody took his bluetooth this
morning yeah it was unbelievable they
mic'd it
they might have it yeah i had a live on
my on my collar and on my
zipper so there you go and the best part
about it sal
it's about discreet it's done online no
visits to the doctor's office no awkward
conversations no waiting in line at the
pharmacy
blue chews tablets are made in the good
old usa
and prepared and shipped direct to your
door in a discreet
package that's the big thing same active
ingredients as your v's and your seas
but it's in a chewable form which i
don't think anyone else does and it's
not a fraction of the cost
the kids can take it
that's right we're gonna say here right
now that's a joke
that's a joke kids do not take this at
all this is for adults as a matter of
fact if you're listening right now and
you're a kid what are you doing what are
you doing get out of here
get out of here get rid of daddy's pills
there you go okay fraction of the cost
uh
a full-size boner full-size barna all
you have to do if you want to discount
and you really want to enjoy
your your nice thick veiny erection what
you got to do
is go to bluechew.com use the promo code
hey babe and you're going to get
your first month free we're giving you a
free month of boners i mean what else do
you want from us guys
yeah bonus were really i mean you know
you know
bonus are free for a long time in life
yes but then sometimes
yeah they're not they're not and then
they're basically making bonus
free again hear about this how about
this go to bluetooth.com
put in the promo code hey babe you're
going to get the first month free
get a boner take a picture of it tweet
it out
[Laughter]
do not do that that's what i need you
doing if you're a lady listening and
your husband can't get it up
why not a little blue chew for for us
tape your intimate moment with your
husband send it to uh
hey babe uh podcast gmail.com we will
review the tapes
and we'll pick a winner absolutely
bluechu.com
promo code hey babe first month free
absolutely that's 30 days of a rockin
hardcock
on us kick off your summer in style
folks with the brand that's reinventing
men's basics you know who i'm talking
about
it's the return of the mac mac weldon
return of the magazine
yes is so much more than just underwear
yeah their full collection
t-shirts polos button ups
shorts pants swims and so much more
light breathable fabric technology mac
welding keeps you cool and comfortable
all summer
i'm telling you right now comfort means
the most to me right look at my pants
right now look at the flexibility over
form i agree with that athleisure many
weldings i got on not the socks
but the pants mac welding everybody
you're an active person with an active
lifestyle yeah
clothing brand it suits your needs how
about you make that up how about this
da and they got the summer wear coming
out you can dive right into macwell
swimline with trunk and board short
options that are quick to dry and have
four-way stretch fabric
and i i wear some of the macweldon
t-shirts in the pool because i'm a guy
that goes in the pool with his t-shirt
on
i do that as well and when you're not in
the pool mac weldon's new maverick
techcino short
and radius short are the perfect
additions to your summer wardrobe
they'll keep you comfortable so you can
confidently power through your most
active days comfortable
number one we're stressing here number
one for 20
off your first order i mean this is a
no-brainer 20 off the first order
go to macweldon.com
hey babe and enter the promo code hey
babe
that's mac weldon.com hey babe
use the promo code hey babe 20 off
your first order mac weldon they're
reinventing men's basics and i'm telling
you
it's worth it it's unbelievable it's
what i'm going to be wearing for the
summer
as am i get mac on the phone i want to
talk to mac somebody call him
i got to meet i got to talk to mack i
got to talk he's a guy right it's a guy
yeah
i want to talk to him he's doing big
things let's here and here's the song
return at the mac weldon divorce rate
for arranged marriages across the board
whether you're in india united states
wherever is only four percent so if it's
really because i think that's the
mentality going in
it's arranged it's already arranged so
your job is to to to see it through i am
fully 100 confident my mother
and father would he would arrange the
100
completely wrong person for me yeah no
they wouldn't even come close
my mother would arrange somebody for me
who i just have no interest in
i just know that for sure i mean when
every time i've been single
some of the facebook profiles that i get
from my mom and dad be like what about
her
yeah your parents send you facebook
profiles
when i was being like it happened a
couple times when i was single when i
was single the last time
my father said i swear to god i'm not
like my father sent me a facebook
profile of a woman
that was my stepmom one of my stepmom's
friends 51 years old three kids she has
been divorced for 15 years
he was like what about her i said dad
she's 51 years old
i'm 33. she one of her kids is 19.
but you but you're giving her a scarlet
letter you just told me you would date
an international terrorist
if i was in love with her right but what
if you fall in love with the 51 year old
with three kids
and she turns out to be terrorists no
that's so saying you're like i can
date international terrorists but you're
like three kids ugh
yeah no no nothing gets 51 year olds i
mean you know i'll tell you right now
those three kids will probably terrorize
you
terrorized yeah well 51 year old is fine
i mean 51 is you know i'm going to be 51
one day hopefully you never know yeah
make it through this cold
but but or allergies but 51 51
i guess the only thing would be is you
know if you're looking for like a
long-term relationship
is it is is a 51-year-old woman and a
33-year-old guy is that
too much of an age gap nah you don't
think so 51 is not out to
that's that's up there 81 what's the
oldest person you could sleep with and
not feel disgusting
not feel disgusting because let me take
that back yeah cause you could still i
mean sophia loren is i mean
and not feel i'd have to say barbara
walters right now not feel something
like unnatural like this feels like
there's too big of a gap between us
disgusting is probably the wrong word
but i was when i was thinking about i
was thinking like a hundred do you ever
see um what's that kenny powers
yeah this is great there's an outtake
with stevie he's telling that he slept
with this woman that in a nursing home
that he used to know and she's like
i think she's like 96 or 103. and he
thinks it's cool and he's like i slept
with her and then like yo you suck with
100 and he tries to take it back
no but like you could sleep with a you
could see what a 90 year old woman
90 years old i don't know that i could
look the woman is has all her wits
completely sound
healthy lives on her own like i don't
mean like she's like
laid up or anything like she's she's
she's pretty independent she's just that
age
breast implants shh whatever you like
i don't like breast implants then no all
natch wow she got well that's 91 years
old
yeah you you you
am i in love with her
is she terrorist sure
i don't think i could actually let's not
even go extreme
at your age right now 43 tissues by the
way at your age right now
do you think you could sleep with a 60
year old
yes okay i'm 36 about to be 37.
you can see what a six-year-old is
spriteful 60 yes okay
65.
only thing is is now 65 or starting to
get to
like my mother's age so
i would say no at 65 60 i would say 60
is my cutoff
55 is preferable
there you have it if we have any
listings 55 or whatever you're a fair
game
i'm into 55. 55 is not that old i mean
i'm 44.
yeah so you're saying like a decade from
now you you you
oh you would sleep with me okay yeah i
wouldn't sleep with you now but
10 years older 10 years very good pimpy
14 hottest
that's a thing here's a list of the 14
hottest celebrities over 60.
sally field 67 god i love her sigourney
weaves
64. jessica langs 64. well i cannot
believe it's not asian
who jessica lang why isn't lang and
irish
an asian last name i don't know
l-a-n-g-e
oh i thought it was l-a-n-g that's still
is that an asian name
let me ask you this sounds like one what
okay so let okay so the e
for you e is a discrepancy that makes it
not asian what if her name was jessica
wang
w-a-n-g-e would you think she's asian
like that's like a seinfeld episode
donna chang
oh that's right yeah but she was white
and blonde
and he and jerry's like you know you're
not chinese
um china obviously no no china
yeah shout out north shout out south
julia christie julie christie said who
christy brinkley i mean sixth smoking uh
helen mirren 68 susan sarandon 67.
i mean all gorgeous women how old is uh
cindy crawford 57. i
am in love with her 55 to this day i
love her so much she's
she's just she's perfect she's just
the tops 55 she's 55 years old betty
now could you what about betty white 99
is that
a comedy legend but a story no
disrespect but
no i don't know what what do you think
the oldest person
uh alive is right now that has had
actual enjoyable intercourse
google it pimp i mean does someone keep
that stat
the oldest person alive right now by the
way is kane tanaka at 118 years 152 days
but lucille ramdan is right there at 117
years 112 days
so she's coming right up that ass game
lucille could take it
if kane drops and lucille lasts another
year
yeah i love the name lucy then back to
back latino tanaka
wait 118 is 118 years
all right you live to 90 fair game like
pretty full life
90. imagine living 28 years
past 90. i mean she looks exactly what i
thought she would look like
barely that's kane's barely alive she
just has a has a
her face is just stuck in a in an open
mouth
like i'm in pain every second of the day
god
bless this god bless cain tanaka which
sounds like a great wrestler's name
yeah the old japan's kane tanaka 118
which means she was born about 1903 very
good with the man 1903
wow wow
she's but she's a she's a global
oh my god do you know she's she's a
global
literally universal treasure
she's the oldest living she's a relic
she's a living relic
every single person out of the 8 billion
on this planet she's
older than 8 billion people the odds of
that she was already
41 000 years old when world war ii
ended
she was 41 she was in her 40s when ww2
ended wait wait wait wait wait how old
are you
36. okay if i'm doing quick math
[Laughter]
she was she was 80 hold on 30 you're 36
36 or 18
gets you back to 18 gets her to 100 you
minus that she was 82 when you were born
when i was born
she was already 82 82 when you were born
she's still alive right now
wow be covered i mean if she like
every little thing you think she'd be
too pandemic
she'd be she'd be the spanish flu she
beat everything
everything she beat aids i pushed she
beat everything how did she not get aids
her up against the grizzly right now see
what happens see what happens
kane tanaka versus the grizzly that's on
the patreon
[Laughter]
it actually sounds like like like a
mortal kombat uh match up
let me ask you tanaka versus grizzly
bear but here's the simple question what
would you rather watch logan paul
mayweather or kane tanaka versus the
grizzlies
versus everyone you know they had those
t-shirts like cleveland versus the world
yeah or detroit versus everybody kane
tanaka versus everyone that's the merch
i want that shirt i want that shirt can
you give me another versus everyone
we're going to do it kane tanaka should
be like our like mascot
yes like the most resilient human being
on the planet
stands a test of time yes nobody
everybody bowed down to kane tonight hey
tanaka are we gonna get kane to knock on
the podcast or what
oh my god only on the patreon only on
the page billion dollar level
one came to a million dollars if you
want to see us uh interview kane tanaka
on the patreon
how about this on the patreon and when
we do lose cane tanaka we will do a live
stream at the funeral just like we're
gonna do a live stream in the funeral
for the fish that's right
wow oh my god wow what did she do she
said
she had pancreatic cancer at 45. oh my
god
the number one death sentence of cancers
she had it at 45. she also had
colorectal cancer at 103 15 years ago
15 years ago what what is this
parathyroid fever
that killed blackbeard oh my god
wait she she would love like to live to
the age 120.
okay i mean come on kane don't push it
yeah and obviously crediting family
sleep
hope eating well and practicing
mathematics which i have actually heard
keeps you sharp up top mathematics yes
i'm very bad at math
what does she eat every day that she's a
hundred and she's so she's gotta be sush
just sushi yeah but what about the
mercury i don't think she
i don't yeah what is she she's also
adopted kids
oh the couple worked in the store
selling shiruko and udon noodles uranus
are very good
she was alive before the car one of her
kids got captured at the end of world
war ii before
flight right
yeah i don't know i don't remember but
it's got to be before flight 1903.
the yankees hadn't won any championships
yet they weren't even a team they were
the highlanders
what what
canada wasn't even a country damn well
maybe they were
she was 20 in the roaring 20s yeah
that's perfect
she's lived through multiple depressions
yeah
she was apparently now here you are
complaining about seasonal allergies
yeah plays
yeah complaining about seasonal
allergies and kane tanaka says what
that's nothing
someone's got to be with her 24 7. now
got to be 24 7. i mean look at she what
just the sweetest
she's just such a sweet woman looks like
wow she's got the guinness book of world
records now is that a title you guys
would really want to hold
oldest person alive you know what
happens as you get older too your
teardrops dry out so she looked like she
was getting emotional but she won't
produce tears
is that that's a true story you tear
your tear ducts dry out as you get older
very old people that can't cry they're
they just have no tear
they have the emotion is there in the
brain but the tear ducts are dried out
can i ask you a question how do you know
this
where did you learn that fact i never
heard that in my entire life
now that you're questioning me on it i
could have made it up okay
let's just see though do tear ducts tear
ducts dry up when you get old
you know what sal you know you've been
carrying a lot of credit card balance i
could see it in your face you've been
carrying credit card balance
and i just want a way to for you to
listen to the face of a guy
he's carrying large balance credit i
mean the credit card balance you carry
we could see it you know fail you know
we've been talking about it and we said
he's got to find a way to get rid of
that credit card balance and we really
had no answers we we
you know we tried to we talked when tony
robbins come on yeah so i took him we
went to your seminar
we had the dalai lama himself kramer was
on they've
all called and warren buffett was on he
said he's carrying his credit card
balance
he he and he talked you know dalai lama
said i've never in the his i've never
seen anybody carry credit card balance
like that
and we were at options and then finally
epiphany happened
upstart.com i'll start yeah fast and
easy way to pay off your debt with a
personal loan
all online whether it's paying off your
credit cards or consolidating or funding
personal expenses
a five-minute online rate check and you
can see your rate up front
for loans between one to 50k yes 50k
yeah right you receive funds as fast as
a business day
after accepting unlike other lenders
yeah upstart looks at more than just
your credit score they look at your
income your employment history this
means they can offer smarter rates with
more trusted partners
which is what you need everybody needs a
smart rate i'm sick and tired of having
these dumb rates
these low iq rates i need a smart rate
and upstart.com help me with that
lower your monthly payments today when
you go to upstart.com
hey babe that's upstart.com hey babe do
not forget to use our url
to let them know we sent you okay we
want we want to make sure upstart knows
that we're sending the hay babers there
the babe so go to upstart.com hey babe
and get the loan that you need today
loan amounts will be determined based on
your credit income and certain other
information provided in your loan
application
so that's not our fault if you don't get
approved for loan you need to get your
life together that's right but you
but if you want to take a chance at it
go to upstart.com
you know what if you want to build a
website seriously because you know we
i think building a website is so
important and so cruce
in in this day and age if you don't do
anything other than squarespace.com
i kind of don't i don't even know if i
could be a friend to be honest with you
if i found out that you were not using
squarespace to make the websites
i'd i'd stop the podcast this might not
even be something that people are
familiar with
but if you want to start a business or
sell
merchandise you need a website you need
to promote something
and you think that you have to hire
someone to do it no you have no basis of
knowledge in the area
we have a solution squarespace is a
dynamic all-in-one platform
that customers can do that they can
build the websites they can claim a
domain
sell stuff online you can market your
brand you can do this
by yourself affordably from your own
home now yeah with squarespace people i
mean
there was a time where i was like
imagine something like that existed yeah
and it does
and it does my mother she's works in the
tech
business yeah and she said to me works
on computers she works on computers and
she said to me and she said oh
she said i'll help you build your
website i'll do it for free i'm your
mother i said listen you stupid piece of
[ __ ]
yeah i know i can do it she thinks she
squarespace.com you tried to get one
over on me mom
you tried to you know try to assert
dominance
she doesn't know about squarespace you
don't need her i said listen lady why
don't you just go make the pies
and take your granddaughter for a walk
or two yeah i'll build my own website
with squarespace.com that's right you go
tech off absolutely absolutely and you
can go build your website at
squarespace.com and get a sweet discount
all you got to do go to squarespace.com
hey babe for a free trial and when
you're ready to launch use the offer
code hey babe
to save 10 off your first purchase of a
website or domain if my mother
calls you looking to make a website do
not
do it she does not want you to know
about squarespace she certainly
doesn't want you know about the discount
i'm telling you if my mother
takes questions stefano calls your phone
yeah looking to make your website
you tell her no lady i'm going to
squarespace.com hey bam i'm getting 10
off your son says yeah
older eyes produce fewer tears wow
i think it's because you've seen so much
[ __ ] that your emotions get hardened
that's true and it's harder for you to
be like to give a [ __ ] yeah
but it's a word for something like you
know how like there's a term for it
where like kleenex
becomes synonymous with the word tissue
like give me a kleenex or make a xerox
of this
xerox is a company that makes copy
machines they're not a photocopy
or going postal that only came out with
berkowitz
yeah did you know that no that's what
that is going postal
the term oh i thought you were making a
joke no the term he went postal that
what came out after david burke was the
son of sam because he was a postal
worker he was a postal worker
you worked for the posters i forgot
about that yeah the summer of the year i
was born i think so
1977 six oh this summer right after i
was born i was alive
but he started at 76. he started you
were born on america's bicentennial
bison 10 babe not many bicentennial
babies left that's right
what look at that oh
painting look at this want to go to a
painting the last painting we got from
tony castus thank you so much
um uh the the great oil painting now we
have another painting
that was sent to us by i want to read
this card we have not seen it yet we
have not seen the paintings
yet and we want pimpsteal where
are we at where are we at oh let's do
this i love it baby this is from
stephtrob527 on instagram
thank you steph we love you steph pimp
chris and sal
i hope you liked the painting it was
really fun to do
you guys literally are the tits
underlined
and i live for your podcast parenthesis
shadow taste buds and chrissy chaos yes
keep being hilarious not underlined so i
can piss my pants
on my way to work every day start doing
the kegels
here are some fun little gems i've
learned from hey babe thus far
elon musk is a good time charlie if i'm
ever facing legal troubles i'm hiring
sal as my lawyer fair enough never
underline let tony decephalo near my
dog's toys
tony de stefano 100 needs his
own show agreed i am sal with a vagina
fair enough let's throw that on a
t-shirt that's gonna be t-shirt i am sal
with a vagina or i am chris with a
vagina or or
i am sal with the penis the penis and i
am chris with a penis
right for those who think that we have
vaginas yeah
for the guy who's like i love those gals
they're like me and for the gals like i
love those guys like me
we have something for everybody always
show love for your favorite companies
parenthesis shout out saratoga peanut
butter
saratoga peanut butter spans all
underlined podcasts
i may have little league elbow i may
have sleep apnea i may have hypochondria
pimp's laugh gives me a hit of serotonin
instantly
never gift anyone a g-star raw gift card
the more i learn about bitcoin the more
confused and opposed to what i
am and underscore i also fear for my
life parenthesis is not dramatic
invest in parappa the rapper not only
can i wait to add to this list but i
also can't wait to vacation together
and become best of friends seriously you
guys blow my balls off and then she did
an illustration of two testicles
and wrote her name steph trump and she
also gave her cell phone number out
which is
[Laughter]
1 800 m-a-t-t-r-e-s so let yes
pimp if you could give us the painting
let me just get one more blow
you might do you need a sharp utens can
do we hands
i'm gonna try to bare hair there let's
do it it looks like it's really done
asking myself right now what would kane
tanaka do would she get utensils
she would should she know what kane
tanaka would do she'd open it with a
freaking
stair out of it and that stuff would
drop right off of it
kane tanaka must have special powers
kane tanaka if you're listening and
watching and we know that you are
we wish you another 118. at this point
does kane tanaka even get the vaccine or
she's like why would i get the vaccine
she is the vaccine she is the vaccine
um by the way today and i will take a
picture of it uh
when i go back but um there's a store
that just opened in bay ridge
on uh ridge boulevard and
68th street 69th street over there um
and
the guy it's like a you know um i guess
english isn't his first language but he
says
you know it's like snacks cold beers and
then he wrote you know once wrote
right fruits and veggies and he spelled
it fruits and veggies
it's va you take a picture you know
v-a-g-g-i-e whatever you think
tomorrow fruits and veggies how cool is
that that
her name's kane a female named kane and
in 1903
you know like oh what's your sister's
name it's like kane
[ __ ] it's pretty cool florence no it's
kane
what's your sister's name gertrude no
kane [ __ ]
wow oh my that is a
masterpiece holy [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] that's real it's a real
painting
this is a real painting the detailing on
that what do we think it looks like
it looks like me this is a 10. that is a
10
out of 10. this is a tent here oh my god
even
even the frame is beautiful yes look at
that
that is an unbelievable look
i mean i mean i want to hang this in the
home the only
issue is i ripped the back sorry about
that i don't
really know what the game is razor blade
i don't know what it i guess it just
protects because when i touched it it
was the rear side of this
so maybe it just has an extra layer of
thin thin paint what are we going to do
should we throw the hey babe sign right
off the roof
i mean next episode yeah okay next up
we'll do that shout out steph traub
um i might hang this just in my hole
though
uh hey babe gallery hey babe gallery is
a good idea that's nice
steph trump 527 on ig thank you so much
this is above and beyond this this
actually i just farted on that sneeze
you did it
you did i'm sorry this actually warms my
heart god damn it
it really does like this is something
else here no it's beautiful we have
beautiful
beautiful 27 episodes in we're framing
the frame
i mean come on guys like like what more
motivation do we need to do
in this 2017 27th episode this is
important because we don't want to be
part of the 27 club
what is that famous artists and
musicians who have all died
like um like sam cook you don't know who
that is
amy winehouse kurt cobain jimmy
henderson three of 27
27
um jesus died at 33 33. so the 27th
episode is big the 33rd episode's been
how about this babe
kane tanaka outlived jesus by four times
four times yeah yeah yeah it should be a
thing where like the oldest person
gets to rule yeah you know so right at
the cane
lucille's up unless lucille takes a dip
right then number three is up
can i ask you a question what is the
oldest person to like what's the oldest
age that anyone's ever
lived to taking guesses 123
that was going to be my french woman a
french woman i got that right wow
jean comment 122. wow
that was just i swear to god that was
just a guess wow you have a talent for
guessing how old people are
than what their nationality was oldest
verified man ever
jeromian kimura who lived to 116
great names coming out of japan wow
jeromian 122
122. once you get past what like
90 so that's 32 years like when you're
like 170
like i don't understand your day-to-day
you're a hundred and let's just call
it your 115. okay and you've made it
that far right
and you're still of sound mind and body
okay but
uh you don't know when you're gonna go
on honestly it could be any second right
you don't know if like something inside
just breaks
yeah what's your outlook
day to day you you rise for the day are
you like today could be
my last day i think a person that lives
that long
i tell you what i think they live they
somehow are
genetically wired to to
to not have stressful thoughts or be
worriers
i'm a worrier i'm probably going to go
at like 65. right you know
god bless you please i want to help you
yeah fame i want to live forever
learn how to fly uh but i think that i
think that's what it is i think that
they're just like
zen people i think that most
likely most likely
you you probably have accepted death
already and you don't it's not a fear
it's not a thing you even think about on
a day-to-day basis when it happens it
happens
surprising signs you'll live to a
hundred you have a relatively fat flat
belly after menopause
so your shirts are still out check when
you got your menopause then we'll see
when is that
usually for women ends in their 50s
40s 50s ends i think
it begins menopause can happen in your
40s or average is 51.
okay let's go back to the other side 51
that's also the
your ideal woman yes uh shouldn't it be
called like
women or pause keep going should be you
were a healthy weight teen
you like raspberries in your oatmeal
talking about do you like raspberries in
your oatmeal i've never had that in my
life
you make every calorie count which we do
you do my fitness pal
yeah you skip cola even diet
you run for 40 minutes a day 40 minutes
a day for 100 years
yeah i'd rather die at 90 and just walk
everywhere what happened
after you turned 100. look at that do
you get
this youtube send you like a black well
i told i told you what happened to my
grandmother i told you that story
did i say this yes i said already on hey
babe where my grandmother turned a
hundred
she got back to back i said all right
but just to refresh
she got a card from president ronald
reagan at the time on her 99th birthday
and that she died in her sleep on her
100th birthday
on the day of on the act the day to the
day
she lived 100 years on the dot what are
the odds of that
what are the odds of that yes it's got
to be i mean what are the odds of that
what are the odds
it has to happen not that many times yes
i mean it's
it's unbelievable she died 100 you told
me that i didn't remember it
yeah i feel like that's something i
remember that she died asleep on her
100th birthday
today only point zero one
seven three of americans lived two
hundred oh that is wow that's
dismissed that's really depressingly low
so one one hundredth of a percentage
point of people
it's not good to as reported in the
article
wow some families have a
disproportionate number of people who
live tonight
it could be in the genes do you know
that there's a disease out there i
forgot what it's called but the way you
die is because you can't sleep
ever again your brain just won't go to
sleep i've never heard it and you decide
yeah and it's like a very very very very
very rare condition
but that's how you die your body is
tired but your brain will never let you
sleep and you never sleep again
until you die but your brain starts to
then uh how long did you go that
malfunction i think
like only like a year it starts to
malfunction and your body starts it's a
year
i thought it was gonna be like two a
week you know your body starts to like
uh wither away you you can't not sleep
for a year it's
impossible 264 hours
10 days 12 11 days no but this
google disease 11 days that you can't
sleep or some [ __ ]
google exactly that let's see yes
fatal familial insomnia ffi is a rare
genetic degenerative brain disorder
characterized by an inability to sleep
that may be initially mild but
progressively worsens
leading to significant physical and
mental deterioration wow
it's i watched the documentary on it
once it's terrifying because this girl
because it's familial so that means it's
only in the family and
the uh the the girl's
father had it and grandfather had it and
they tested her live on the show to see
if she had the gene because then you
know what's hard to happen to you
and she didn't have the gene but not did
not but they made it like a maury povich
like opening up the card like just
i was like this is terrible this is
horrible because what if they were like
you got it
then everyone's just like oh
how do you look her in the face imagine
imagine they go
imagine while you're watching the
documentary
like you know like oh it's just going to
have this disease and then they go you
got it this has been hey
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away
from your feelings babe don't be afraid
don't be ashamed don't hesitate to say
hey
babe hey babe hey babe hey
babe hey babes hey